about 8 000 children and teenagers are
reported missing in our state every year
and most vanish right here in Las Vegas
many are also considered runaways who
leave their homes and end up in unsafe
situations Sasha Loftus spoke with the
family tonight Who's frantically
searching for their 15 year old who's
been missing now for a week she joins us
now live with their message
Denise that team's parents have been
putting up these flyers all over the
city for days now they say even if their
daughter did leave on her own they need
to know that she's safe
days after their daughter vanished
Autumn and William Trejo are doing
everything they can to bring her home
we're not complete with our
fifteen-year-old Julie Trejo has not
been seen since last Friday and her
parents are worried she's in danger and
it's hard for me to walk through the
house and not see her there
so they're now spending all their time
canvassing neighborhoods in North Las
Vegas where anyone could have seen her
this is very very Troublesome we would
like to find Julie Samantha Potts of
local organization missing Justice is
helping with the search
she says cases like Julie's which North
Las Vegas Police has classified as a
runaway aren't uncommon according to
Nevada homeless Alliance our state has
the highest rate of unsheltered
unaccompanied kids in the nation while
about three-quarters of teens who've
left home returned safely Potts says
these situations still deserve time and
attention they are absolutely in danger
because they may have ran away and
linked up with the wrong people as for
Autumn and William they hope their
efforts will encourage anyone who may
know something to help make their family
whole again Las Vegas please bring our
baby home
now Julia was last senior Commerce and
Ann last Friday she's about four foot 11
around 90 pounds with brown hair and
brown eyes if you have any information
you can call North Las Vegas Police or
missing Justice we have more information
on our website 8newsnow.com reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now